foreign
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where America hangs out to
have a conversation about your wife
about your money I am your host the Jade
warshaw I am joined by Ken Coleman
America's career coach in the house in
the house thank you Ken uh and like I
said we're here to talk about your life
and money so give us a call the number
is triple eight eight two five five two
two five and we will chop it up with you
let's go straight to the phone lines we
got Amber in Los Angeles California
what's going on in California Amber
hey how are you doing good how are you
good good thanks for taking my call
um I'm a new listener I still Motocross
the YouTube channel about probably like
a day after I prayed for financial
guidance
um I'm 33 I'm single I'm in California
I'm a registered nurse
um but growing up I never really had any
Financial guidance I saw my parents
struggle going through bankruptcy and I
kind of feel like I'm going in the same
footsteps
um after I found the show I enrolled in
a Financial Peace University but I'm
kind of stuck on baby step one
um I don't really have any extra funds
left over to cover like minimum payments
for my debt so
um kind of just stuck like what do I do
in that situation that's such a good
question and I think a lot of people
find themselves there
um typically when you find that you
don't have any margin left right you're
barely covering minimum payments there's
no money there it's usually a
combination of a couple of things one
your actual core income
it's probably not high enough it's not
sustaining your life it also could be
that you need to cut back in your
lifestyle or it might be a combination
of the two so let's get a little bit
more information from you what's your
current income
I make about ninety thousand here
um my my bed is a lot of student loans
but there's also Consumer Debt there
sure
um my student loans
um probably about 194 000 because I went
to a private school it's pretty
expensive and then
credit cards 20 000 personal loans
thirty eight thousand 38 000 okay what
kind of degree do you have
I have my bachelor's that I'm in school
for my Master's I'll be done next April
what field is it
uh nursing sorry okay
so you do have a lot of student loans
what's the minimum payment on those
student loans
the minimum is like 1500 a month because
I have such a high interest rate yeah
because they're private what is it like
7.5
um one of them is the other is 11.5 yeah
those things get that those things get
high fast okay so we're working full
time we're in our field like you said
these student loans are just and you've
been paying them the whole time because
they were never put on pause right
because they're private
um right what is what have you been
doing have you just been barely getting
by are you using the credit cards to
fill in the Gap is that where the credit
card debt is coming from
right exactly the credit cards and the
personal loans yeah it started with I
had to pay taxes one year for off of
work and I didn't have that emergency
fund or any kind of money saved so I had
to go out and get a loan and then kind
of just snowballed from there are you
currently on a budget
I did
um look through I enrolled in every
dollar
um and I looked at everything and I'm
not really spending much outside of my
bills I don't really have extra to spend
so constantly have like a negative
account or I have to borrow from like
family or friends
so what I want what I would say is I
want you to get back on that every
dollar budget because it's just good to
keep those numbers in front of you plus
you're going to start working to get
more income coming in because that's the
only solution to this problem if you've
got a big hole you need to have a big
shovel so for you that's going to look
like doing extra work picking up extra
shifts side hustles whatever you can do
to get that extra margin I mean five a
thousand dollars would make a huge
difference for you right now going
towards your debt right
yes yes what is your rent or mortgage
situation
my rent is 2 100 a month and it's kind
of hard to find something cheaper I
don't really have sure family that I
could live with and I I that's what I
how many kiddos you said you're a single
mama no I don't have any kids I'm sorry
so you are single
okay I'm looking for a roommate I know
that's right
um I I think Jade's absolutely right on
you need to make more income and I'll
I'll add to that in a second but if I'm
you I'm finding a roommate stat Los
Angeles there's got to be plenty of
other single ladies out there that you
can interview and you got good you got
good sense and just find somebody who's
willing to live with you because they
need to cut as well and let me just tell
you something if you get a roommate
and do you have two bedrooms
no just one oh geez well I'd get a bunk
bed honestly I I you know I I understand
you if you've got a one bedroom that's a
little bit different so I didn't want to
go too far down that but I I would be
looking at stuff like that you know do
they have a do you have a couch
and would someone like to save eleven
hundred dollars a month I know you would
am I right
you're right why wouldn't you try that
you have nothing to lose but that's
Eleven Hundred Dollar raise by getting a
roommate look I'm Amber can I just tell
you ah you're single when my husband and
I were paying off our student loans
which by the way
um there was one of them that was around
194 000. uh we got roommates as married
people Ken why not and look 10 out of 10
would not recommend that but if you're
getting out of debt for a short season
for a short season
you used your brain heck yeah you had
some discernment you probably had a
process they weren't ax murderers no
they were old friends and we we decided
that we would try it for a year Amber
and after a year we were like okay
that's enough but in your case you might
be able to have a better situation
because it's just you it's not for
people to navigate you know a space it's
totally worth it eleven hundred dollars
times 12 months you know what that
equals would that change your life
dramatically Amber
you know they would definitely help out
all right now now that I know and I
misunderstood I thought you were single
mama so now I'm going all in all right
you're single you're a nurse I'd be
pulling every extra shift that I could
possibly get and Amber I'm not talking
out of my motivational hat here
I remember about a year ago I was on
with Dave Ramsey on this very show and a
nurse stood across the uh Studio to us
on the debt free stage and talked about
how she was working 60 and 70 hours a
week and she paid off 200 and I want I
think it was sixty thousand dollars
worth of debt wow so Amber you've got a
very nice profession
you have got an opportunity to go out
and work I know that the nursing
industry is strapped and there is
opportunity for you yes or no
yes and I've actually
um just recently got hired for a per
diem job so I know like good I'll be
able to do it but I think I'm just
scared about like I don't have the tools
you know you do you didn't grow up with
that no Amber listen we're going to walk
with you we're gonna walk with you
you've got every dollar you've got FPU
you're going to get in a class you're
going to sit them out sit among other
people who are trying to figure it out
and we have got the baby steps all you
got to do is walk it out I also want to
give you something I'm going to give you
uh Dave's wildly best-selling book Total
Money Makeover to read one chapter a day
while you're going through FPU you know
what to do at Amber you can do it I'm
not betting against you but you better
go get busy get a roommate on that couch
and get you a whole lot more hours and
before you know it you're going to be
rocking this thing and in the meantime I
want you to go sign up for Rachel
cruises every dollar webinar she's going
to teach you exactly how to do it that's
August 24th be there Amber you need this
thank you
[Music]
hey guys being free to make your own
medical decisions is a big deal these
days Christian Healthcare Ministries
gives members the freedom to choose the
doctors and providers they want without
the frustration of worrying about
networks and with no waiting period to
join it's a membership-based non-profit
Ministry where hundreds of thousands of
Christians share funds to pay for and
pray for each other's medical bills for
over 40 years chm has helped families
living across all 50 states so cfchm
could be right for your family check out
more today at
chministries.org budget
thank you
[Music]
all right you're listening to the Ramsay
show I am Jade warshaw joined by Ken
Coleman and um you can give us a call if
you want to talk about whatever's on
your mind Triple A
825-5225 but I'm gonna tell you guys
what is on my mind and it's probably on
your mind as well and that is student
loan skin watch out folks I'm warning
you she's amazing she's delightful but
she's about ready to fire it up I mean
look here here's where it lands you guys
know I'm gonna talk about student loans
until I'm blue in the face and you
probably know that the Biden
Administration opened up a new loan
repayment plan it is called the save
plan it says this new repayment program
opens today for more than 20 million
student loan borrowers and these
payments are based on their income and
their family size okay the vitamin
Administration announced that the
savings on a valuable education program
that's the acronym I don't know why they
do that they just want something to
sound good so it's really just called
the save plan freaking freaking
bureaucrats that's all you do they just
want it to sound special just know it's
called the save plan okay it's one of
the many I should say one of the four
income driven repayment plans this is
the newest one because the the program
will calculate your monthly payment like
I said based on your income your family
size and the hope that they're hoping is
that it will help you quote save money
on payments now let's stop right there
the way we teach I don't want you to
save money on payments I want you to pay
the thing off so I don't want your
payment to go lower necessarily I want
you to spend more money
monthly towards your debt so it can go
away faster right can I point out that
this is there's some Shenanigans in this
there are some Shenanigans this is this
is this is what you understand and don't
get sucked into this I'm just gonna I'm
gonna give it right back to you where
you were but I want to point out why
Jade's right
this program is an end around the
Supreme Court's decision the Supreme
Court said that Biden acted illegally in
trying to forgive student loans so what
does the Biden Administration do they
come up with this Nifty little program
and this is in the fine print
this program will calculate monthly
payments
based on borrowers income and family
size the administration estimates that
under this new save program more than a
million borrowers listen to this will
qualify for zero payments
zero dollars in payments it's an end
around this is what they're saying is to
Americans we feel your pain and they're
going we're gonna try to fix it where
you don't have to pay anything back and
then they're gonna go well based on this
uh some only will save about a thousand
dollars a year but this is all about
making sure that the interest doesn't
balloon but this is another political
tactic and if you go along with this
you're going to say thank you Uncle Joe
that you're never gonna pay this off
well here's the thing you know and and I
want to talk about this practically
because what I see on social media is
folks saying Jade why wouldn't I do this
the interest is not going to accrue it
doesn't matter what my payment is at the
end of this term no interest will accrue
and they'll forgive whatever's left not
gonna happen well here's the thing no
one is thinking about how long this is
okay you even if you had it starts at
nineteen thousand dollars right if you
have student loans as low as nineteen
thousand dollars you're still in for a
bare minimum of 10 years
you would have to pay a bare minimum of
10 years to get that proclaimed for
Freedom at the end and then for every
thousand dollars above that
another year okay so for most people
they're going to be looking just and
this is just averages all right most
people are going to be around 30 25 to
30 years paying back right that's not
worth it can I just let me let me tell
you guys a little story most of you guys
know that Sam and I had uh around 280
000 of student loans and a lot of hours
were private loans okay so we didn't
have all these options they were not
talking about repayment okay uh this was
back during the Great Recession that we
started paying our loans off Ken so you
know the world was going crazy very
similar to how it is right now now it's
inflation back then it was the housing
market gas prices all that crazy stuff
and
let me tell you my husband and I there
were different types of payment plans
back then and we hopped on a couple
because it was like okay our student
loans are so expensive we could not
handle them like we could not pay them
uh we didn't have enough money and I can
tell you even when you go on a payment
plan and it lowers your payment from 500
to 84 you still feel the weight you
still know those loans are there they're
sitting there they're waiting for you I
cannot physically imagine having that
there for the for the next 25 years you
want to talk about cutting years off
your life the stress the amount of
stress just knowing they were there now
here's what I do want to say because I'm
about to flip the script on some of
y'all
when it comes to these income driven
repayment plans the only time and I say
only in big red bold letters with lots
of exclamation points next to it okay
the only time I would ever consider a
payment plan like this is with the
intention of lowering my monthly payment
temporarily can so that I can get as
much money in my budget to throw it at
the smallest debt in my debt snowball
sure you got it do you hear y'all feel
what I'm saying I wrote it down in case
I forget are you in trouble okay I don't
want nobody get out there if you sign up
for one of these income driven repayment
plans just simply to Kick the Can down
the road thinking you're gonna get
forgiveness after 25 years y'all need to
stop right now you're just playing
yourself but if you really want to play
it right what you need to do is like
okay if my payment matter of fact I have
actually a picture of one of salmonized
payments that we had this was from is
this navient this is just one set of the
many loans we had you can see there the
payment is somewhere around 500 and some
odd dollars and we are able to work with
them to get the payment down to 257
dollars and we did that to free up more
money to go to our smallest debt on our
debt snowball we did that temporarily
and then when it came time to pay that
debt we were hitting that thing with a
machine gun as quickly as we could so
there is there is some smart guidance
around this Ken but what I really don't
want people doing is saying oh great I
can pay zero dollars I'll just ride that
way forever that's right terrible idea
yeah because here's the deal you don't
know what administration's coming in
next and who's going to be in charge and
this idea that someone from the
government is eventually going to agree
with this person folks I mean you don't
have control over that no I don't like
that idea of holding it and holding it
holding it and holding it and think
about it these are the people who helped
put you in this position the government
guys it's true they have never put you
first it's impossible for them to put
you first there's too many of us they're
gonna do what's best for whatever
Administration is at the time only you
can put you first well let's remember
that there's been no conversation in
Washington DC about stopping the federal
student loans
so while all these people are supposedly
being forgiven or hope to be forgiven
they're still Doling them out to this
new fresh crop high school students that
are about ready to go into the next year
and yeah and so you've got to understand
folks this is a game that you haven't
set the rules for that's right you
either play the game or get out of the
game and we're here to help you get out
of the game I know that's right and
we're doing that we are doing a student
loan this is awesome live stream guys
this is what we need to be telling you
about you and Dave Ramsey and Rachel
Cruz teaming up that's right September
12th it's Friday is it it's free it's
absolutely absolutely yeah guys we're
going to walk you through because I know
y'all half the folks can are like stop
talking and just tell me what to do tell
me what people tell me what I'm supposed
to do we are going to tell you exactly
what to do matter of fact I was in a
meeting yesterday with the big eagle
himself uh-oh Dave Ramsey and he was
like I'm a big eagle as opposed to the
bald eagle I see what he is the big
eagle man he was like I don't want to
spend a lot of time with any fluff I
want to get down to business these
people want to know it yeah and that's
what we're gonna do guys sign up we want
to just you know save your seed it's a
live stream we want to know that you're
coming so sign up it's no uh it's
September 12th you can go to
ramsaysolutions.com student loans and
while you're there there's also some
things that you can start doing today to
start preparing for these payments
because they're coming back Ken they're
coming and listen to Vengeance I want
you folks to post this if you're a part
of our tribe and you you want to help
others you have a lot of power on social
media post the link ramseysolutions.com
student loans it'll bring up a real
really cool graphic make you look like
you know what you're doing in social
media tell people it's free even if you
don't
you're not alone you know someone who
has students oh it's gonna be great I
love it this is what it's all about guys
we want to bring that hope it's not
hopeless please please believe me if I'm
standing here with zero dollars of
student loan debt so can you the time is
gonna pass anyway most people are able
to do it in 24 36 months we see it every
day this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
hey Dr John deloney here I'm a huge fan
of both meditation and prayer and good
mental health includes slowing down
gaining control of your thoughts and
plugging into something bigger than you
and Halo makes it easy to start a daily
practice of meditation prayer and
finding peace Hollow is the number one
Bible app in the world and you can
tailor content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to meditation and journaling
hallow makes it easy to practice prayer
meditate and build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and ReDiscover
true peace go to hollow.com Ramsay today
to get three months of hallow for free
that's hallow.com Ramsay
foreign
[Music]
you guys are listening to the Ramsey
Show I'm Jade warshaw this is Ken
Coleman and you may not know this well
all month long we are giving away cash
here at Ramsey Solutions and you could
have the chance to win we do this a
couple of ways each week we give away
five hundred dollars and then at the end
we give away three thousand dollars to a
lucky winner which is pretty cool you
can do this guys you can sign up to win
and you know cast your Vote or whatever
by going to ramseysolutions.com cash
giveaway I gotta be honest I love this
because people need this cash to pay off
debt Ken Coleman we're walking through
baby steps any little bit helps and it's
funny because people come through here
all the time and they're like Jade I
can't believe it I actually won the cash
giveaway right and I love it because
it's Dave's money not my money okay I
know that's right although we do love
being generous with Dave's money
not even with a little bit of Chemical
Romance I do it just sounds more fun to
say it that way but no it is this is
something we always look forward to it's
an annual tradition yeah and you can
enter to win once a day so keep coming
back that uh always increases the old
chances I'm guessing I don't know you
just keep signing up signing up signing
up and there's also some great deals on
a lot of our products as well so August
is always like a second Christmas around
here yeah some people say Christmas in
July we say Christmas in August that's
right but yeah all those books are on
there and you know we got uh John
deloney's Books yearbooks are on there
you can get these books for as low as
twelve dollars I like to point out that
I have two teenage boys so I need help
with groceries so you can make your
donation by buying one of my books a lot
of bacon a lot of bacon there's also the
questions for humans cards that are
there which are such a big hit I love
those yeah have you ever used them yeah
but I'd rather you talk about my
products because I don't get paid on
them all right you know
right now
I've got our Ramsey Ramsay bips
Community which has got a bazillion
people in it that's a lot and there was
a girl in there she was like I cannot
figure out I'm 19. I can't figure out
what I want to do with my life I was
like I know just the thing career
assessment there it is clear assessment
that's a great product that's there as
well and again all proceeds go to
groceries
groceries for kids Ken's kids that's not
above Gravely about my grocery bill with
two teenage boys they literally have
hollow legs you know this is coming
Hollow legs yeah they can eat and eat
and eat and eat that's just part of
being a teenage boy you know what I mean
look one day your little man is gonna be
eating you out he only is is he already
my guy can eat okay he can eat this boy
I'm like how are you eating the same as
well all right that's it guys head over
there we want you to go to
ramseysolutions.com giveaway you can
sign up to win you can get yourself some
books some content some questions for
humans all at a discounted rate and you
do not have to donate to Ken's kids fund
no you don't have to let's go to Audrey
in Macon Georgia what's going on Audrey
bye hey how are you doing
good how are you good how can we help
my I guess my question is
am I crazy for thinking I'm gonna be
able to buy a home before I'm 36. I read
a statistic the other day and the new
average for first-time homebuyer is 36.
well you know do you want to know how I
feel about that kind of stuff
I don't really let it carry I don't
really let it get to me because at the
end of the day like stats are great but
you get to choose if you're going to be
part of the statistics based on your
actual situation in the situation that
you create for yourself right numbers
change when people change so let's get
into the specifics here what what do you
need to get out of what kind of debt do
you have how long would it take you to
get up a nice down payment the way that
we teach so what are your realities
I am in my last semester of college I
have about
two thousand dollars on my credit card
from school
so I don't have I don't technically have
student debt okay that's good any other
pay on that credit card monthly no I
have no other debt are you single
um no so that's the other half my
um boyfriend we plan to get married
they say it's easier if you buy a house
when you're married
let's talk about that how old are you
okay go into that yeah I am 23. okay
you're 23 you've got a boo and you guys
are planning on getting married when
um we don't really have a timeline on it
okay how am I
I mean we're thinking
she's young Ken she's 23. yeah oh no you
see you took that y the wrong way
I want to know is this the guy is this
the guy for you I'm not rushing you I'm
just saying this is the guy does he
think that you're the lady she said
comma however I would hope so oh you
better know so is what that's my whole
point right well that's why they're not
married yet because she doesn't just
it's not written she don't know yet I
know but my point is don't go into this
thing like well I might get married
because of a house it's like no no no no
no no yes you see where I'm coming yeah
she put in the cart before we know we
won we know we want to get married I
just never put a big I've never I've
never been one to be like we have to get
married at this time
so
um okay so let's let's approach this as
though it's just waiting on me to get
out of college before we move forward
okay I'm fine with that that's fine Jade
you took issue with saying well she said
it's I've been told it's easier yeah to
get a house in your mirror and you were
like whoa so what's going on with you
um one thing doesn't really have to do
with the other for me
you you deciding to get married or not
get married to this dude that's one
choice and then home purchasing is a
complete other thing separate from that
so let's talk about buying a house when
you're buying a house what denotes
um Audrey when it's time to buy a house
is if you can afford to buy a house
that's really the biggest thing based on
based on your income based on how much
you're able to put down based on if you
are in a secure job that you're going to
be able to continue you know there's so
many things there so in your situation
what's your living situation right now
I just live at home I virtually have no
expenses okay so what I would tell you
to do I'd say Audrey set aside a
thousand dollars today as a starter
emergency fund and then I would say
Audrey pay off this two thousand dollars
in credit card debt and cut up the card
never to be seen again and then I would
say Audrey I want you to build up three
to six months of expenses because I
don't want you buying a house without
savings if you buy a house without
savings that is known as a disaster
because
right home ownership costs money okay
money don't get me started okay don't
get me started on a house you know
suspense I'm looking at a roof right now
a roof situation the AC the AC water
leaking yes and these don't cost a
little bit these cost the most so you
need that three to six months and then
you want to start looking at setting
aside a down a down payment okay down
payment you're looking at 20 you know no
less than 10 percent like we want to get
that down payment up there but then you
also have to think of other things that
go along with buying a house like
closing costs and and earnest money and
all these things so you need to have a
nice stack of cash is what I'm saying
all right right and that's what I've
been trying to do is put away cash I'm
just scared it's not enough well what
you can do is run into Solutions has a
really great uh it's a how much home can
I afford calculator that's great and you
can go in there and you can plug in your
numbers because at the end of the day
here's what we're looking for this is
the the formulation for Success we want
the payment to be no more than 25 of
your take-home pay right so if you end
up getting married after you got married
if you two did buy a house no more than
25 of your combined take-home pay right
that's what you're looking for on a
15-year fixed mortgage
yes no none of this 30-year business so
that's yeah that's that's what we're
looking for so use that calculator and
see are you making any money yet
I am but it's only part-time I'm an
intern at an accounting office yeah so
first things first we got to get the
money rolling in consistently we got to
figure out you know I don't know that
that's the next step for you moving
forward it sounds like there's some
relational business that needs to be
sorted out but uh that's what I'm saying
let's commit come on I'm old school
let's commit what is this dating for 10
years family heirloom so we're on the
way there okay I like where this is
headed that's what I'm talking about so
you know it's first things first you
know if it if it turns out it doesn't
work out with this guy you still know
the blueprint and maybe on Down the Line
you'll get a home however it happens
it's gonna happen the right way because
you've got the right information girl
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a hundred if you run a
business with different software systems
that don't talk to each other that's why
there's netsuite by Oracle in the early
days of Ramsey we were using different
systems for all of our business units we
needed one single source for accurate
data netsuite was the software we used
to optimize and take us to the next
level netsuite gave us the visibility
into all of our numbers so that we could
communicate across departments and plan
ahead better and as we grew it scaled
with us next week worked for Ramsey and
it will make a difference for your
business too join the more than 34 000
customers who trust netsuite to help
make them smarter and make better
decisions and level up their operations
to learn more get a free product tour at
netsuite.com Ramsay that's netsuite.com
Ramsay
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
show I am your host today Jade warshaw
joined by one of my favorite co-hosts
ever Ken Coleman there it is folks
that's money well spent right there it
gets you a compliment like that I say
that about
we love you as well
we two five we want to hear from you we
want to answer your questions we want to
know what's what is it that's going on
in your life that's making things
frustrating with your money is it
somebody in your family is it your kids
is it student loans tell us what's going
on we will do our best to help you out
but I also want to say for all of our
folks who are listening for the first
time you might be listening and you're
like man y'all are out here talking
about all sorts of stuff that I don't
understand I heard you talk about the
baby steps I heard you mention a debt
snowball I am new here and I want to get
the lingo I want to make sure I'm on
board with you guys so if you're a new
listener and you want to dive deeper
into our Ramsay baby steps I would tell
you to go to ramsesolutions.com and
click on the little get started button I
think it's up there in the right corner
uh we'll help you figure out what the
best next step is for your financial
Journey based on where you're at today
okay so that's ramseysolutions.com and
click that get started button and we'll
be there to help you out in the meantime
let's go to Bailey in Green Bay
Wisconsin what's going on Bailey
hey thanks for taking my call everyone
awesome how are you
I'm doing fantastic how are you doing
good so what's going on
so as a lot of people My Generation
Um I went to college I got a four-year I
worked about two or three jobs every
semester so I could minimize my debt and
I didn't need to take out certain loans
I'm currently around 22.5
in
my student loans okay and looking at the
repayment right now coming to us like a
giant looming cloud Over the Horizon
torpedo exactly
um I was just kind of wondering I had it
also a little bit of personal debt but
I'm getting that paid off
shortly thankfully what's that um the
personal day uh I had a couple things
with my car go wrong and then a couple
other things okay
um so it's around like it was around
like 3 000 but I'm just getting out of
that thankfully so that's it it's just
the 22.5 and the 3000 for the car
yeah pretty much
um when you say pretty much sorry I
gotta be clear pretty much or that's it
yeah okay it is sorry
um so I was wondering I've already sat
down and have calculated how much
interest I'm going to lose in each of
the loans
um and I know that debt snowball says
hey do the smallest one first but if I
can knock out
um one that's just slightly bigger than
the smallest one that's going to lose me
more money in the long run should I get
that done right away or should I go for
the smallest one
your opinion
um you know I'm I'm team debt snowball
and I'm team you know paying off the
smallest debt first and here's why it
mathematically it does make sense what
you're saying oh pick the one with the
best interest with the highest interest
rate and do that one first
mathematically speaking I get why you're
saying that but there's more to it than
that and we have found that when people
start with interest rates or they try to
do these other things it takes longer
and it takes you longer to feel you know
that adrenaline hit from getting a win
and so when my husband and I were paying
off our student loans we listed them
smallest to largest even though uh some
of his private loans man those interest
rates were upwards of seven and a half
percent 11 and we chose to pay off one
of my student loans first because it was
a lower payment and it was a lower I
mean the balance was lower so we did
that one first and it felt great it was
like oh my gosh we did this and then you
go to the next one you like oh we did it
and it just creates that motivation so
there's a reason
to do it that way so I would suggest
listing them from smallest to largest
and paying them that way and honestly if
you go back if you're intense about this
if you go back you're going to realize
um the money that you may have missed
out in interest it's negligible because
you're going to knock these out so quick
I mean it's twenty two thousand you're
gonna knock this out within the year
okay
yeah and like looking at other people
I've graduated with and like my siblings
uh shout out to my siblings
um my sister actually just got out of
student debt congrats this uh anyway
um just seeing how much people pull out
is just insane and like I came out with
less than a year of my debt thankfully
um
it's a lot of work but yeah
um so that's pretty much all I all I was
asking about I appreciate it a lot
absolutely
I think by the time
uh if I you know go right to the
grindstone with it
um I think I'll get about 25 of my loans
done before payments resumed look that's
what I'm talking about how much are you
going to be putting towards this monthly
oh my gosh uh I just got the the email
speaking of looming clouds or Torpedoes
there's about 281 and I was like I could
do what I was at yeah absolutely yeah
hit these things with a Vengeance how
much are you bringing in each month
about 3 500. I just switched jobs so
that's kind of why I was in between a
little bit with uh the personal load so
yeah if I were you I would are you
single
I am I didn't the person know with the
last caller
um I I definitely know for sure and uh
we're committed so okay okay well then
yeah pay these things off go hard in the
paint pick up some extra work I think
that if you went crazy you would be
surprised how quickly you'd pay these
off
I think if you went bananas yeah you're
single dude you should be working
obscene hour selling everything that you
don't need I mean just the intensity of
this to knock this out
it's a very very doable 22 000 seems
like a large number but uh it can go
pretty quickly with steady activity and
right now is the time before you put a
ring on it before you close the deal and
get the deal done and start a married
life I would try to get this done if it
were me and I'm saying you have to but I
would try to pay this off before I got
married I would not want to bring that
to the marriage that's what I would do I
love it that's a great call real quickly
let's go to Mary she's in Buffalo New
York what's going on Mary
hi
um I got a summons from
um attorneys who collected it
um just before I called I called them to
set up a payment plan they wanted 30
down and 300 a month the debt is nine
hundred and nine thousand nine hundred
and two
um
I I told them that I could not pay this
um I did offer
a hundred dollars down because that's
all that I can do and 25 a month
um and when I say that's all I can do I
mean we don't have
Disney or Netflix or any streaming
services we're not eating out we're like
Bare Bones
um we have paid off
um other credit cards and stuff like
that so I mean we're doing the baby
steps but they want this now and I've
just summons I had 20 days to respond
and I responded and she the woman that I
spoke to was rude she was like why are
you even calling me these people are
mean these people that you're dealing
with Mary are the worst of the worst
they are scummy mean people they are and
they're gonna try to strong arm you and
they're gonna try to intimidate you to
do this what I would do if I were you is
I would stack up a bunch of money as
much as I could
um because at the end of the day they
are going to settle this with you so I
would stack up money and and forget all
this 30 down nonsense I would move this
to the front of the list because you're
getting sued so I would stack up my
money and I'd say hey this is all I have
take it or leave it and there you're
gonna have to push on them a lot and in
order to make this happen but I want
once you get that offer I want you
getting getting it written in cash or
I'm sorry not in cash I want you to get
it written down sent to you via email
print it out keep it forever right and
then you're gonna go and get a money
order and send them that check do not
ever give them your account information
don't give them anything about your
debit card information because these
people are certainly scummy and it
sounds like they're kind of being
manipulative a little bit and they're
kind of trying to bully you yeah it's
emotion they have to get her afraid it's
getting a job the more afraid you are
the more they feel like they can
manipulate how much you give them you're
in charge remember this
they want your money yeah so they can't
get it if you don't got it so you're
driving this train now do it exactly the
way Jay told you you take control of the
conversation and you guys get serious go
make some more money sell some stuff
take control of this you are in charge
not them that's right that's what I
would do those companies man can they're
the worst of the worst I've dealt with
them oh yeah you know it's part of the
game right they're trying to manipulate
you you got to tell them to put it in
their pipe and smoke it oh all right
that does it for this hour of the Ramsay
show we'll see you next time
foreign
hey what's up guys it's Jade if you love
the show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramseysolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving in storage Studio it is the
Ramsay show where America hangs out to
have a conversation about your life your
money I am your host Jade warshaw I am
joined by Ken Coleman look Now's the
Time to call in give us a call Triple A
825-5225 I'm the money person and Ken
knows all about what you're facing when
it comes to your careers he's there to
help you find work that matters find
what you were born to do Ken what you
were loved to do 96 of the everyday
millionaires that we studied over ten
thousand of them we found that 96
percent of them loved their work they
enjoyed their work and that means when
you're doing what you know you're good
at what you enjoy let me tell you what
happens this idea that oh you'll never
work a day in your life that's not true
you work harder because you're more
fired up and the income gets really
really good and you're able to
prioritize your life so a lot of people
wonder can I change jobs to make more
money or to do what I love while I'm in
the baby steps that's a big question
that is the answer is yes
explica por favor well we'll take those
calls but you certainly can because
you're not going to just jump into the
abyss of the unknown that's true you are
going to stay in that current job and
you're going to do what it takes to get
there I help with that all the time on
the Ken Coleman show help here on the
Ramsey Show today yeah but then we step
from the boat right onto the dock and so
that's the idea so there is no
interruption of income uh with what we
teach and if you can make more money a
lot of our debt free streamers report
making their income go up during their
Journey so just going to point that out
I'm here to take any questions related
to your work that's changing
transitioning starting over starting a
side hustle can I do it while in the
baby steps how does the work and money
thing come together well it's always
together and so if I can help you make
more money I'm here to help we'll take
those calls as well I love that life's
too short to not be doing what you love
um you know about how much time you
spend at work so much time so much time
you need to be doing what you love so I
would even challenge anybody who's
listening to this right now to start
asking yourself a couple of personal
questions about how do you really feel
about what you do every day because some
of us can we just go through the motions
we we don't stop to that's true to honor
ourselves enough to go do I it's a very
interesting thing you said there honor
ourselves I love how you said that you
know this idea if you just grit and
parrot instead of going is it possible
that I could make some money the money I
need and do something that I enjoy where
I get valued and cared for a lot of
people don't think that's possible but
anyway we're here to help in that as
well as your money questions as well I
love that well in the meantime let's
hear from Chris from Hartford
Connecticut all right Chris what's going
on how can we help
hello yes um I'm a husband
um and a father of four kids
um we have over 100 000 in debt based
around different things we sold our
condo for 60 000 and we now rent
um through our employer okay um I use 20
I use 20 000 of that to get all of our
bills
um current and so at 40 000 of that my
wife suggests that I put in a separate
account I did not and that dwindled away
in a year just simply because of I say
simply because but because of family
expenses so right now I feel like I'm
drowning in expenses and anything that
focused on maybe a credit card I'm
pulling from rent but if I don't I don't
want to if I want to pay rent I'm
pulling some student loans then I'm just
concerned because we can get to that
garnishing standpoint so I'm really
trying to figure out where it is to to
start and yeah um just to note that both
me and my wife we work at the same place
it's a very very flexible comfortable no
commute situation for us so I'm the only
driver so me changing a job completely
changes the dynamic so I'm trying to to
figure out how to work through this okay
just at first glance at first pass
listening to the situation it just
sounds like there's no control it just
sounds like you're just flying by the
seat of your pants just putting out one
fire after another yeah yeah yeah
how much money is coming into the
household each month
um I make 80 my wife makes 30
um total we met about 7 700.
each month
how old are the kids
um we have 11 9
2 and uh just a one and a half week
build okay so is there child care or is
your wife at home what's the situation
there
right now my wife is at home but we have
had child care so this summer it's been
a little bit of a break for us on that
but I know that that eventually will
come back in order for us to keep
working so I need to understand
um you guys have a good income where is
everything going you're not you don't
have this mortgage that's inflated
because right now you're renting right
what are you paying in rent every month
1700 okay that's fine wow where where's
my money going Chris
it's not daycare yeah yeah
um I'll just say uh this is from uh I'd
say years of not really focusing on on
budget
um I've budgeted and I have the Excel
document of all of our bills but when it
comes to our like I would say
operational gas
clothes diapers food
um that part has not been budgeted as
strong and so I've been working on that
okay so so where I'm going to push you a
little bit Chris all right because
Jade's a lot nicer than I am where do
you think it's going
that's really good income where do you
think it's going
I think it's uh one thing I could say is
to go on toward uh all of us being in
the family we don't eat out a lot
um but it's going towards feeding the
family
um and then we do have some
extracurricular no for the kid no it's
not sorry I'm calling BS on that because
it doesn't cost you you're not spending
four thousand dollars a month to feed
your family
no no we're not we're not and if you are
something's wrong okay here's what I
want you to do
um it sounds like you it sounds like you
treat the budget the way I used to treat
a budget as long as you know the big the
big ticket items I know what the cell
phone bills are I know what the rent is
I know what gas is everything else kind
of ends up in a pile of discretionary
funds and it just gets piddled away
that's the only way that you put away
forty thousand dollars
um in a year's time that's true of
sitting money right and the thing is
you've got these kids and they want
school supplies and they need this and
you're taking family vacations and
you're doing this and that that money if
you're not planning for every dollar you
will see thousands and thousands of
dollars piddled away month by month okay
that's just the way I mean in that way
Chris you're no exception it will happen
to anybody so what I want you to do is
get on an every dollar budget
um not a spreadsheet because
spreadsheets is is on your computer it's
easy to set it and forget about I don't
want you to do that I want this thing on
your phone where it's on your phone it's
on your wife's phone you're taking it to
the grocery store with you it's updating
it's telling you what's going on on in
real time and I want you to do a brand
new budget every single month because
every single month is different and what
you're going to find when you do that
budget Chris is that you're going to see
oh my gosh we are blowing through so
much money every month and you're going
to start to see line items on there that
you were treating as mandatory but are
actually discretionary you don't have to
do that stuff every single month so you
can find ways that you can cut your
budget I want you to sign up for Rachel
cruises every dollar webinar she is
going to walk you through like literally
take your hand and walk you through how
to do this budget I want you to sign up
you can sign up at ramsesolutions.com
budgeting I am I believe that's what it
is they'll put the lower third on there
for you to see it but I want you to sign
up for this because this is what's going
to break you free the budget is where
you find the money most people are able
to find nine percent of their income
just by doing a budget Ken
they've got plenty of money to do what
they need to do but you got to know
where it's going that's right you got to
find that money and we'll help you do it
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
there
they're one guarantee and shipping is
always free see whyblinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings go to blinds.com now
and save 40 off selected products visit
blinds.com today for more info
[Music]
thank you
you're listening to the Ramsay show I'm
your host Jade warshaw joined by Ken
Coleman and we're talking about
everything going on in your life with
your money your career sometimes we jump
into that mental health space of Dr John
deloney's on but today is me and Ken so
give us a call the number is triple
eight eight two five five two two five
and Ken will help you walk down a path
to finding work you love so if that's
the boat that you're in give us a call
and of course I'm here to help you out
with the money stuff you are and the
last time well I don't know that was the
last time but a few times ago we were on
together and if you missed it I guess
you could find it on our YouTube page
but uh Jade brought in
food items for me that's right and she
was showing me the difference in the
budget because we were talking about
budgeting and every dollar and most
people blow their money on food 100
whether it's eating out our groceries
yep in that particular show
uh I believe you brought in
ketchups yes and he brought in fries
from downstairs at Ramsey Solutions
these were great fries and they were hot
yeah they were and then you were like
you had three you had a name brand
ketchup yup you had a middle of the line
brand ketchup and then generic ketchup
that's right and then you do the same
thing with cookies Oreo cookies the real
deal the knockoff I think that's what it
was yes that's right good memory and
I'll just be honest with you folks I
came in today expecting to eat I thought
oh Jade and I are back on together
so I'm like that's it I got one shot at
a taste test
we'll bring it back and you know next
time we'll talk about the difference
between when you buy the pre-packaged
stuff like right like you can buy the
the little bags of chips or you can buy
the little bags of Trail Mix or you can
just buy the big honking bag and put it
in a Ziploc bag yourself and save a
bunch of money see this is what people
want to know you know how to save money
on food and a lot of people don't know
how to save money on food they're
they're out here can buying the Quaker
oatmeal in the individual little packets
right spending three and four dollars a
pop and while you can is it true that
these companies they've started putting
less and less in there a lot more air oh
yeah they call it a shrinkflation
hey that's real by the way that is so
real because let me tell you these tater
tots they don't go as far as they used
to
if it was a bag of tater tots I buy it
got the size for the same price are you
so you're a bulk Shopper uh for the most
part you know I can freeze family of
four okay five-year-old three-year-old
lots of snacks in the house at this
point Ken that's boy that's true this is
the snack the age of snacking so yes you
got more goldfish than you've ever
thought you'd ever have I don't want to
tell you Ken what I spent at Costco last
weekend
I don't want to tell you no
this is hitting Americans by the way
this is an idol Chit Chat we're talking
about budgeting and food is one of the
biggest issues and this is what's
hitting America by the way you look at
the inflation numbers just everybody
knows why we're talking about this
inflation right now is back up it's
moving up wear gas groceries and you've
got to figure out how to game this and
you talk about this a lot on your
Instagram account at Jade warshaw by the
way that's right we saw we saw grocery
inflation at 12.4 percent Ken it's
freaking you out when you see the number
it's a lot and you know how to shop I
know how to shop and we have a good
amount of margin in our budget but
everybody I don't care what your budget
is it you either felt this or it it
pounded you yes like it pounded you
because to say oh you know I was
spending it now I'm spending 100 more
every time I go shopping
100 turned into twenty dollar bills yeah
nothing costs twenty dollars what would
you say I'm putting you on the spot yeah
but I know you can handle this what
would you say
family of four not teenagers I got
teenage boys so they eat like that's
they're the two teenage boys are the
equivalent of six humans yeah when it
comes to eating all right and I know I'm
griping about it but that's my reality
let's talk about real things let's talk
about a family of four like yours little
ones so they're not eating enormous
amounts of food what would you say is a
reasonable grocery budget based on the
times I'll tell you
um so if you read the articles out there
if you read the sources they'll say for
a family of four on a healthy yet modest
budget is somewhere around 987 a month
which that sounds
dead honest with you guys oh
four uh let's see right after covid I
was spending about a thousand dollars a
month on groceries and then when
inflation started I was like this is
crazy and it was hard for me because I
was like I feel like I you know you have
to face what's actually happening so I I
did some research and I found an article
that said a family of fork has been
anywhere between 800 and 1200 a month on
groceries so I upped our budget to
twelve hundred dollars a month had the
margin to do that however there have
been months where I've been like okay
since it was at twelve hundred dollars a
month I've got so much extra in the
cabinet than there's months that I can
drop that thing down to like 800 700
because I'm using the stuff from the
month before like I've been using the
extra stuff in the in the pantry that's
why I led you there yeah cause we got
people listening watching going I can't
do that no so what could they do can you
do it can you do it 700 a month what are
you talking what's that look like what's
a 700 a month grocery budget look like I
have been working on content here Ken
you can get that thing you can get that
thing I don't like four or five hundred
dollars I thought so you can here's the
thing noodles
rice okay okay okay
chickpeas black beans how many proteins
do we got in that budget a 400 a month
how many proteins you can do a protein
every night you got fish yeah chicken
look it is we're not doing filet mignon
you're not doing filet you're doing talk
you're doing ground beef or ground tofu
tacos you're doing steak that's tougher
than you know yeah or you know you might
do spaghetti some nights without putting
beef in the sauce because you're trying
to save money you can still make some
nice red sauce you know you're you're
having breakfast for dinner you're
having you know pancakes yeah it's
doable it is so doable the thing is I
think as now I'm saying this from a
female perspective I think sometimes as
moms or maybe you're the dad in the
house that cooks we want to do the most
it's like a way to show love and so it's
like we want to have this beautiful
plate that's got four I don't know why
maybe it's just me a plate should have
three things on it is that just me
the plate for me the plate should have I
see that but I like the divider if I got
three or four things I'm like a little
kid I don't like my food touching I want
the divider plate here's what I've
learned these your family they love you
they don't care if you give them grilled
cheese they're actually kind of happy
about that because who doesn't love
grilled cheese if you give if you serve
pancakes for dinner no one is
complaining it's totally true and you
ready for this uh because James child is
our fertile series a very healthy eater
he's a very clean eater he's in the he's
in the booth going just pancakes for
dinner
listen I endorse balance of nature here
on the show guess what you can have your
pancakes and you take your balance of
Nature and you got your veggies no I
don't know fruits and veggies so now you
got your pancakes you swallow your three
little fruits your three little veggies
hey we got a balanced meal my friends
from balance of nature yes
I'm just pointing it out but also eat
your fruits and vegetables
you don't have to when you have balance
of nature that's the whole point it's
not a gratuitous mention it's actually
very practical that's good because I
like one green I like two greens yeah
broccoli and green beans outside of that
I don't like much do you know what you
can do the occasional green pea most
places you can go online if you just
search online whatever the ads are in
your neighborhood any grocery store and
find the cheapest price if you take that
over to Walmart do you know they'll
honor that see this is why you listen
and watch the Ramsey Show yeah don't
make sure we don't miss that if you
Google because there's a lot of these
little um grocery stores that are like
really small mom and pop stores that
maybe will sell things cheap or
um you can go on there and Google like
Save A Lot okay even if you've never
gone into a Save-A-Lot if you Google the
price of Save A Lot grapes and they're
usually the cheapest you take that or
Bravo they have a store by me called
Bravo I don't go in there and do you
have to take a screenshot take a
screenshot of it print it out and say
hey there's something you're telling me
they will add match that junk you walk
that up to the cashier at Walmart and go
let me show you a couple pics man and
they will honor it they'll honor it
they'll add match it do I and it's if
somebody does there's a little social
anxiety with that are you in line and
everybody's waiting on you and yourself
I used to go straight over to the the
customer service I go straight over
there but can we don't care anyway we do
not I know but see what do people think
I was bringing up an objection and you
smacked it out of the park yeah so you
don't care what everybody what's she
doing up there let's go lady you're like
listen I'm saving money wait your turn
please sir that's what I say so what I'm
hearing you say Jade is it is possible
to Budget on groceries and food even in
inflationary times there was a time we
spent 60 dollars a month
a sixty dollars a week
I did that math real quick I'm like
that's not right 60 a week I think you
were rationing not budgeting now if we
can do it you can do it that's good you
got this America you got it
[Music]
foreign
buying Market but there's a way you can
get an edge Churchill Mortgage works
with you to understand your budget and
your goals and the Churchill Mortgage
home buyer Edge offers you fast
pre-approval and a secured interest rate
plus Churchill has bumped up their
seller guarantee to ten thousand dollars
giving your offer the best chance of
being accepted and helping you win in
today's market go to
churchillmortgage.com today to learn
more
[Music]
thank you
all right what's going everybody on
everybody you're listening to the Ramsay
show I am Jade warshaw your host joined
by Ken Coleman we are talking about your
life and your money give us a call the
number is triple eight eight two five
five two two five let's go directly to
the phone line can because we've got
Elijah in Fort Wayne Indiana and he's
got something to talk about what's going
on Elijah
hi Jade hi again thanks for taking the
call of course
hey so um I have a question I'm a little
bit in a predicament I don't know if
it's me just getting Panic or what it is
but
um I worked at a fire protection company
Here Local to Fort Wayne
um for about four years and then I just
left there back in January oh what kind
of company
uh it's a fire protection I was an
engineer there okay gotcha
yeah and so I left there after working
there for four years
um basically because work environment
um just kind of deteriorated uh
especially caused by the pandemic and
everything a lot of people ended up
leaving and the company just didn't live
up to its Glory Days so I ended up
taking a leave as well and took a
different engineering job for Less pay
during that time I was living at home
and just saving up money for a house and
and then I just recently purchased a
house about a month ago
um and so I took this job for Less bunny
on this new one and now I'm getting I
think a little bit panicked as far as
the month of Dales utilities and
everything and I was just recently
approached by a buddy of mine who now
works at a different fire protection
company for significantly more than what
I'm making
um and so I'm tempted to take it however
I really enjoy the job that I'm at right
now albeit making significantly less
um okay hold on one second what is
significantly less give me a real number
here
okay so I whenever I was uh working at
the first company the first fire
protection company I was making 65. okay
a year whenever I left um and then I
took a new job at a small company I'm
still engineering but a different uh
industry okay
um and I am now making it's instead of
salary I'm making an hourly wage which
if you do the 40 hour work week I'm
making about 56. what I was approached
with with the other fire protection
company was 75
as well as they have some sort of
freelancing incentives as well for
instead of doing overtime I could take
on extra work and all right so all right
so we'll come back to work in a second
but I want to go now to the money piece
of this
are you panicked because you've made a
bad decision and you've gotten too much
house or are you panicked because this
is your first big boy move and you've
never done this before and you're kind
of scared because you don't know what
you don't know and it's just kind of new
it's changed it's a big step what's
causing this panic
yeah the panic I think is more so the
probably the big boy purchase
um it's the first I mean obviously I
bought and I bought a car before but
this is like have you run the numbers on
the house and what you're going to be
paying in mortgage and homeowners
insurance wrapped into that all together
you run the numbers based on what you're
making right now
uh yes I have do you have margin
I do okay then should you be panicked
probably not
how much I just want to know how much
margin what are you bringing home about
four thousand dollars a month
uh
uh yeah uh I mean if you take my
take-home pay yeah it's it's at three
thousand okay and how much is the home
payment
uh home payment uh just mortgage around
his 959 with Insurance included in there
it's 11 19.
okay
it might be a little tight yeah and
you're at a third and that's why you're
feeling tight
so but here's the challenge with this
um I don't want you taking a job
doing something you did in the past that
you didn't really love
and leaving a job that you really enjoy
for
what amounts to
um let's see when it comes down to take
home it's not going to be that much more
okay because here's what's gonna happen
you'll take that job with more money
because you're feeling tight because you
you did you did bite off a little bit
more than we would want you to chew I'll
let Jade walk you through that
um but it's not the end of the world but
but putting yourself in a job situation
that you don't enjoy you're going to end
up resenting that house and you're going
to end up presenting this decision so
the question is do you have a ladder
where you are in this work that you
enjoy do you see a normal path to some
promotion and leading you down the road
I'm thinking 10 15 years from now that
you're doing the work you really want to
do
um
maybe uh uh it's a very small company
but it was bought out by a holding group
that owns some other companies and their
grand plan is to combine all the
companies so yes if their plan goes
according then I can see a ladder but
that's dependent on on their future but
you enjoy this work
absolutely really enjoy it
yep okay and are you single
uh yes okay
have you already bought this house is
this a done deal
yeah this is a done deal I own it now
okay well you know what I I think
because you bid off a little bit more
than you can chew you have to decide
this is not my call I personally would
not leave a job I enjoy to go do a job
that I don't enjoy just because I'm
going to get a fifteen thousand dollar
bump okay because after taxes at 15 you
know what I would do if I were you I'd
find a way to freelance and do some
stuff because I'm single
and you might be ready to mingle but you
might have to put that on hold a little
bit and go you know what I bit off more
than I can chew and so I'm gonna big boy
right now Jade yeah and I'm gonna go I
got some skill and I'm gonna go make an
extra thirty thousand dollars okay and
put all 30 of it on the house and
essentially make up for what he should
have put on in the down payment that's
where my head's going that's interesting
do you agree or disagree uh well I would
want to know do you have any other debt
Elijah
uh no no other debt look baby step wise
you're pretty close to that because
let's see are you investing 15 percent
uh I was up until the career change I
got standard five right now okay yeah we
yeah the numbers the number holds yeah I
mean I'm sorry I I'm glad you said that
I want you to use the baby steps I want
you to get to emergency but what I mean
is is if I were you you've already
bought this house yeah you got to make
make it work so my point is he needs to
go make some more money he keeps working
the baby steps but he could still knock
that he could knock that down well can I
ask a career question because I okay so
Ken and Elijah you say you love the job
you're in and the other job option it's
in the exact same field what makes us
feel that you might not switch jobs and
also love it because it's the same it's
not like you're switching fields or
trying something new it's the same
profession is it the same profession
um it's a it's well it would be
technically the same profession as an
engineer but it's in two different
Industries my current industry would be
in industrial mixing and the other
industry is fire protection right so it
is slightly so slightly different he's
an engineer but it's a different
industry so my point is here is this is
income I would fix this and I would get
my income up
yeah because I would get through the
baby steps start investing uh the 15 get
the emergency fund up first then that
baby step four but I would really be I
would be increasing my income
so that I could start working on that
house knock it down but I've got more
margin because right now yeah I mean you
plan to get married one day yes
oh boy did you hear the crickets well I
think we may have lost awesome that's
okay if we lost them because I kind of
want to go further on this all right go
for it because can I think you know
people get themselves in this situation
a lot yeah and we're like hey you know
side hustle get you a side Hustle but in
this case if this is a long-term issue
where something short-term like side
hustling may not be the move not and I'm
not saying that you were saying it's a
move but I'm saying out there in the
culture it's like just side hustle your
way side hustles are great but you also
have to be real about the reality of
your situation
and whether or not it requires you to
make
um changes to your core income that are
sustainable yeah right so with this guy
I mean he said he has a possible path
that's why I'm saying yeah
uh we yeah we're not going to be able to
get him back because we're running up
against a break that's true I I would
say this you're absolutely right but in
this situation because he really enjoys
the work
I think he for the 15 000 to go do
something else I'd rather him go make
that on the side yeah while he is seen
if his path does allow for a promotion
that's good that's good yeah because
he's got the ability to do yeah you know
that uh side I wanted to increase his
income until he finds out what his
relationship situation is he may or may
not but theoretically
he's probably gonna eventually get a
woman in there we got a double income oh
yeah eligible eligible bachelor it's not
the end of the world but he usually
increases income absolutely not at the
risk of doing something you don't enjoy
that's good Ramsay show
[Music]
hey if you're in over your head with
student loans and tired of getting calls
from collection agencies if private
student loan debt is taking away your
financial piece and you don't see any
way out you need why refi they're not a
debt settlement company and they're not
connected to a bank why refi refinances
defaulted private student loans that
other places won't touch and gives you a
custom loan built for you based on your
ability to pay so when you refinance
your private student loan debt with why
refi you'll have a payment you can
afford with a low fixed interest rate
you couldn't get anywhere else to help
you stick to your budget and work the
debt snowball and you can save thousands
of dollars to learn more about this
custom refinancing option and a lump sum
payoff option you could qualify for
after 24 months call 8442
Ramsey or go to
yrefi.com Ramsay
[Music]
thank you
what's going on guys you guys are
listening to the Ramsay show I am Jade
warshaw he's Ken Coleman he's our career
guy so if you have anything going on in
your world as it relates to your career
we want your question we want to help
you out and by we I mean Ken because he
is the expert on such matters no you got
you got something to say about just
about anything and it's gonna be good
that is you know we're good we're good
that is true by the way I gotta if
you're watching on YouTube or you're not
watching Jade is is looking very very uh
wedding minty today you've got the
jumper is that what you call that a
wedding mint you got that that cool
green thing going today yes cooler than
the other side of the pillow that's my
favorite from Stuart Scott
R.I.P Stu Scott come sports center that
is that's a high five right there let me
tell you something what's cool with that
there's no other Ramsay co-host that's
gonna get that reference I love that
there's no chance that George Campbell
or John deloney or Rachel Cruz have any
clue what that phrase means that is one
of the many reasons why you are
fantastic you telling me in the middle
of the night when it gets hot you don't
flip the pillow over so you can sleep on
the cool side come on I go one better I
asked the wife
flip your pillow
I'm like no no no no no no no no no she
bought me a special cooled pillow oh
yeah it stays cool does it work yes see
I got the target version and mine
doesn't work you need to get your you
need to get in every dollar and save
your and get your budget line item for a
stay cool all night pillow because
that's what I got it never gets hot look
you one thing you guys need to know
about Ken is when it comes to Comforts
Creature Comforts it is no cost there is
nothing that this guy will not do I
don't want to see you guys you're draped
in velvet kid I'm telling you I don't
sleep on anything less than 750 thread
count either that's suffering oh my
goodness all right let's go to Nathaniel
he's in Sandusky Ohio what's going on in
your world Nathaniel
yes sir
good hey I appreciate y'all uh having me
on here um I I had a question
um I work a job that is a regular income
I work in sales and live off of 100
commission and I am ready to move out of
home
um I have been living at home now for
the last two years and after listening
on the show it's like I I should make
that move to make the move out
um
but uh and curious in doing such you
know what are some strategies living on
a regular income to be able to do so to
be able to you know
um
survive I guess on a regular income
where months maybe are on the low end
where you're you're just barely scraping
by and to provide some more insight as
well I do have a base residual that I
get based off of the portfolio I have
how much is that done
so it it varies month to month
um you know this past month I netted
about 15.70
um off of that alone
um and that is kind of what I'm trying
to use as my base in treating anything
past that as extra income
um in in using that to build my budget
but uh is it real estate what kind of
work do you do
so I uh work in uh the merchant services
industry probably one that's not uh very
well viewed by uh the the Ramsey team
collectors
not quite collectors no no no so uh we
do Financial technology so we do things
like point of sale systems additionally
okay
um credit cards you're saying because
you process credit cards
I got a question uh Jay's gonna help you
out but I am curious the 1570 is that uh
if you look over the last 12 months or
so how consistent is the number around
that I mean how often is that kind of
the Mark or near that Mark
yeah
um it's it's close um I mean it goes up
month by month
um
is that the low Mark over at 12 months
I would say over 12 months the low Mark
has been about uh you know 1200 to a
thousand okay all right on the low end
what do you think Jay Burnett I was
trying to get clarity and when you said
1570 I was like is he saying 15.70 an
hour is he saying 15 000 700 a month I
was trying to understand what the fifty
is it one thousand five hundred fifteen
hundred as a residual base okay yeah
yeah
um and then what's the commission above
and beyond that what would you say is an
average look over the last 12 months and
give us kind of a an average
yeah my lifetime average monthly growth
has been about fifty four hundred
um on an average for the last two years
um within the last 12 months that was uh
upwards to
um
you know I would say within the last 12
months it's been around uh seven or
eight thousand wow that is good
so I had a really good July what are you
so nervous about man
um
I don't know I guess part of it is
um the the parents push me ah you don't
have to move out don't worry about it
and other things and
um I think part of them are afraid to be
empty nesters themselves but
additionally well that can that part
can't play into your decision yeah you
gotta go out and be a grown man dude
come on is it that you're trying to are
you trying to go straight into like home
ownership and is that no
no
or yeah I've got about 86 000 in student
loans I'm paying off
um at the same time as everything else
and then I've thrown around the idea of
getting a duplex but it has kind of
withdrew the the decision to do that
based on
um again listening to the Ramsey Show
and hearing uh how that's probably not
the wise choice but I should keep
knocking out debt before I so something
tells me those student loans are they
Federal loans
yeah I've got one that is uh 33 000 all
in my name and then a parent plus that's
53 that I still want to pay back
um what was the plan on the 53 Parent
PLUS Loan because that's in your parents
name
yeah I mean I'm putting I'm planning on
paying off the 33 first and then the 53
um I want to pay that back as well
because even though it's in my parents
name it's not I was still the one that
went to school whether I'm using my
degree or not
um I still feel like that was invested
into me okay um that's your yeah that's
your choice
um I think this I I have a guess that
the pressure that you're feeling and
what Ken is picking up on is about these
student loans because you've been living
life and you've not had to budget for
that payment you've not had to consider
that really think about that debt for
the past three years and now it's coming
back and it's like oh how is this going
to affect things am I right at all on
that
yeah I I have paid off quite a bit I've
been implementing what I could for the
last two years I paid off over 32 000 so
far out of 121 total I had uh over ten
thousand dollars in credit card debt I
knocked down and then almost 12 000 in
medical bills my friend I'm jumping in
because I don't think this is a money
call
I could be wrong I don't think this is
my call I just heard enough Jade he's
responsible he's done enough for this to
know he's responsible he can do this I
think Jade's right I think you're a
little bit worried about taking on the
new payments but I think my friend
you're just like every other human on
the planet you're afraid of the unknown
and I think you're afraid of also
disappointing your parents
I'm gonna keep it real with you I think
that's what's going on and I think
you're trying to make the money thing a
crutch or you called us to get us to
nudge you and push you to do the thing
that you really want to do but you're
afraid to do yeah that's what I think
now you tell me if I'm wrong and I don't
mind being wrong
and I think that you're you're probably
accurate in that
um
time for you to live your life how old
are you
uh I'll be 30 in October dude get out
there Mom and Dad are gonna be fine it's
time for you to leave the nest you've
got what it takes with financial
experience and that you've paid stuff
off before you've got a very good income
do not make an excuse with your regular
income I know that's not leave mama and
daddy plus we got every dollar for that
they can help you out with that paycheck
planning just slide on over there yeah
just go see them every Saturday morning
let Mom put cook some pancakes or
something that's right get out of the
house dude do your own freaking laundry
live your life gee whiz oh man by the
way he does need to get get on every
dollar though get that get that paycheck
planned on every dollar because having a
plan getting into this matters I do want
you to pay off your debt but you can do
all of that this is the Ramsay show
hey folks Ken Coleman here did you know
the Ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world it's your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
Ramsay Network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
foreign
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving in storage Studio it's the Ramsay
show where America hangs out to have a
conversation about your life and your
money I am your host Jade warshaw joined
to my right by the illustrious Ken
Coleman illustrious that is a word right
there I like that
I usually Reserve that for George
Campbell but really you were you can't
come up with a different word for the
two of us well look at this this with
this hair you got going on today Ken
illustrious was the word it's the same
do every time this is a toupee I've had
for a decade
yeah we're taking calls from you guys so
give us a call the number is triple
eight eight two five five two two five
we know you're out there we know you're
feeling stressed yes and you're feeling
anxiety around your money around your
career whatever the situation matter of
fact
we're all feeling it right and Dr John
deloney actually has a new book coming
out about this it's called building a
non-anxious life and I'm so excited
about this because I'll be honest Ken I
didn't think I needed it I didn't think
I needed to read about this stuff but
now reading it like this helps everyone
yeah sure it does everyone you need to
pre-order it no one is and we walk
around thinking we've got it and like
I'm good I'm good I've got this i got
this you read this book you're gonna be
like oh there are some changes that I
need to make there are daily choices and
he actually walks through a set of daily
choices that you can make every day to
start I walk around knowing I don't have
it and it actually makes me less anxious
because I just know I don't have it I
hear like I know I ain't got it together
I don't know what I'm doing I don't know
how I even got in the room how did I
even get here at this table I know
that's right but look six daily choices
come on I like it because just like we
talk about the money and the baby steps
he's breaking it down really in his own
kind of baby steps on how you can rock
this thing
by the way when you pre-order now you
get it at a discount and a lot of
goodies I love that yeah you if you if
you pre-order it today you can do that
for twenty dollars
but you're getting 75 in goodies as Ken
would say
um one of those things is access to his
talk it's called smoke fire and freedom
and I heard that talk yeah it's good and
it's off the chain it's on point
um then you also get an ebook or an
audiobook of him reading uh building a
non-anxious life so that's pretty sweet
you can do that at ramseysolutions.com
I've already got my copy is y'all's turn
now all right let's go to the phone
lines we got Mike in New York City
what's going on Mike
hi thank you for taking my call Jaden
Ken uh Ken great reference to uh Stuart
Scott you and I are the same age that
was wonderful yes sir yes sir franchise
and Stuart Scott days Dan Patrick those
were the days man that's when
SportsCenter was you couldn't miss it
you had to watch you miss it you had to
stay up and watch it back in the 90s
into the 2000s I'm gonna give you this
Mike just for you Booyah oh yeah
I love it those guys were wonderful you
and I are the same generation so totally
awesome thank you you're very welcome
I've got a question um I'm actually
around 60 miles east of New York City
out here in Suffolk County Suburbia and
um got a question regarding the 3B to 4
5 and 6 process 3B as I understand you
look to see when you're purchasing a
home to have the mortgage no more than
25 of your take-home pay after taxes
okay my question was as soon as you hit
3B everybody's going to be now going to
four five and six definitely four five
at maybe at some point if at all and
then six definitely wouldn't be when you
go right to four five and six now you're
contributing to fifteen percent to your
retirement you're possibly doing a 529
and you and you're also finding extra
money to throw out the mortgage that's
right so wouldn't those numbers be a
better true tale or sign of what your
take home or what your mortgage would be
what you can afford forward than just a
3B because as soon as you do 3B now
you're now I'm contributing to you know
the 15 and my my take-home pay now
decreases so my percentage of my
mortgage might increase it might go from
as an example 23 and jump up to you know
29 yeah you don't want to know the
thoughts on that
um I think that's actually what you're
saying it kind of answers the question
itself I think that's the reason that we
speak in this as percentages as opposed
to actual dollar amounts because then
it's customizable for your situation
because for most people not everybody
but most people it's kind of like okay
I've got my income I'm putting 10 for
tithe I'm putting uh 25 give or take on
my mortgage I'm putting another 15
retirement that leaves me that's 50
there and that leaves me another 50 for
you know the other needs and wants of my
budget that's the other 50 where there's
a little extra going to 529s which by
the way that's 1 area that we don't say
it's got to be this person or that
percent some people might not choose to
do any so that kind of frees up an x
amount of percentage there and then the
whole thing with the mortgage is really
how you know it's not about intensity
it's about intentionally putting aside a
certain amount whatever you decide for
some people it could be three percent
for some people it could be you know it
really is
um discretionary on that area so does
that answer your question a little bit
no it definitely does can I just maybe
just add one thing so I'm thinking as I
go through that process of 3B into now
four five and six that I want to kind of
be a little more cautious because I know
four is right around the corner and I
know five will most likely happen and
six will definitely happen so I don't
want to be like house poor if you will
because four five and six that's
probably the bulk of where the majority
of people are on the baby step process
probably spend the majority of their
time in those years of four or five on
those steps so four five and six well we
see that most people they walk through
baby step two 12 24 months and then it
takes them about seven years to walk
through from the time that they hit baby
step four it's about seven years that
they're able to get in there seven and a
half seven to ten years of actually
being able to pay off their mortgage and
that's just that's just an average
that's not saying it's the case for
everybody but it's usually around seven
to ten years to get to that paid off
mortgage possibly baby steps
millionaires situation
okay yeah because I understand what my
situation once I get to 3B 4 5 and 6 is
going to be putting into 403 B's I have
a I work as a a public school teacher so
I have a guaranteed pension in New York
state so then I have the 403 b option
um and that's gonna that's gonna uh you
know reduce my take-home pay
significantly and then I have you know
the flex spending plan you know
um a teacher's dues which are you know
around a thousand dollars per year so
there'll be other factors in there
besides just the you know the federal
standard taxes yeah yeah that's
something to think about
um you know at the end of the day with
pensions obviously we say 15 with
pensions you have less control over that
money so we don't really fully count all
of that towards the 15 we usually say
count about half of it towards your 15
percent and then you mentioned the 403 b
that's I mean that's cool and then you
said there were some other required
contributions as well well it would be
like you know my teachers dues and then
also the um the flex spending plan which
I elect to do because that's just a
no-brainer you know the cafeteria plan
where you pay for you know expenses that
aren't covered by your uh co-pays and
stuff so you've got a lot in there the
good thing again is this is based on
percentage so at the end of the day if
because of these extra things you're a
little over 15 that's okay it just means
on down the line you might not be
putting as much money to I don't know
paying off your house but it's all good
you're still Building Wealth and that's
all that matters at the end of the day
so very very good question very good I'm
giving him another Booyah that's what
I'm talking about this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
you're listening to the Ramsay show I'm
Jade warshaw joined by Ken Coleman we're
taking calls all afternoon so give us a
call at triple eight eight two five five
two two five and we'll talk about your
life we'll talk about your money Dave
Ramsey says we'll talk about you right
in front of you I like that uh Ken let's
do this question of the day all right
all right the question of the day is
brought to you each day by neighborly
your hub for Home Services
neighborly.com is the place to find
Reliable help for your home from locally
owned businesses like Air Serv we got
dryer vent wizard Precision garage door
my nickname in high school was dryer
vent wizard just an interesting point
didn't happen no it didn't none of those
things are true but we are Genie keep
going window Genie would be a nice
service I need to get my windows cleaned
up I'm not getting up on a ladder and
you're not gonna let him up there no way
or he's refusing which is the truth no I
don't want a National Lampoon's
situation on my hands
all right I'm gonna call I know Sam he's
pretty Nimble he's Nimble but I'm
calling window Genie and I'm gonna pay
all right a nice that's a good
reasonable fee for them to do it so for
expert help with just about anything you
need including cleaning your windows
visit neighborly.com today's question
comes from Brittany in New Mexico I'm 28
and I'm in baby step two I really
struggle with staying on budget since
I'm single and I don't have that
naturally built-in accountability
partner who do other single people use
for their accounting accountability
partner to stay on track and meet their
financial goals this is a good question
Brittany what do you what do you think
Jade what do you what are you hearing
here you need single lady out there all
the single man there it is you need a
best friend
you need a good a BFF they call it yes
is that still a thing I'm a little
outdated I'm old okay we'll go with beer
you're being very polite right now oh
it's now a bestie you need a bestie look
I'm not much younger than you can let's
be honest you are we you need you need
the right people okay and I'm gonna
explain to you right quick what this
what these people are or this person
okay they need to be someone who you can
trust all right trustworthy they need to
be someone who's walking the walk right
legit so they can't talk it can't be
uncle boo-boo who's always talking about
oh yeah you know you need to get your
money right and uh the cryptocurrency
yeah he does it has to be somebody who
has money you can't take money advice
from broke people okay and Uncle boo-boo
is broke he's not the one okay you need
somebody who will tell you the truth
uh-oh truth teller hold you accountable
right and and it's not that they're
judging you they're just saying hey
didn't you say I I thought you said you
were sticking to your budget and I but I
also saw that you were going to brunch
with you know Monica and them right
Monica Monica will get you in trouble
she will so you need somebody who will
say those things to you and hold you
accountable and then you have to be a
person who's able to receive it because
at the end of the day it doesn't matter
how that person is if you aren't willing
to receive the feedback if you're not
willing to receive the accountability
you're dropping it now because that's
the real deal you can have all the
accountability in the world but if you
just not smile and wave
it ain't worth nothing but a chicken
wing at that point no thing but a
chicken wing this is great this is my
favorite segment ever now ever I love
everything we've just dropped here all
the words we got Monica yeah we got we
got we got Uncle Boo Boo Uncle boo-boo
now let's try let's go let's go a little
further into this um I can't wait to see
where this goes well I want to talk
about this because we get this all the
time man it's hard for me I need
accountability it's hard for me to stick
to my budget and we talk about it like
it's kind of um like it's a trait that
some people possess and some people
don't great call you're right these
types of people they got the gene no
those they're just disciplined people as
though we came out of our Mama's womb
disciplined I don't buy that no I think
that things like discipline and and
doing what you said you're gonna do
those are skills I agree with you that
you build and develop and test
and challenge in yourself over time I
agree hit me with some hit me with some
knowledge God for you is amen that's all
I got I mean I I could take an offering
but that's all I've got left after you
did that that's absolutely right because
here's what you're saying
when you think that you are essentially
making an excuse you're counting
yourself out you're going I can't do it
because I'm not as organized as Jade or
whatever I get that I think you're
absolutely right it becomes a it becomes
a crutch that we go well I'm just not
good enough so really good stuff love
the question Brittany that's a great
question and and the budget by the way
if people are saying well Jade how do I
build that skill when you start a budget
give yourself that accountability and
when you say to my to yourself okay
start start small everything is not
going to be perfect all at once but
maybe it's just one line item okay this
month no matter what I'm starting to the
grocery budget gotta get in the gym yeah
that's the idea that's how you build
muscle you have to show up a little
throw some weight around and figure it
out yeah let's go to the phone line
Dominic San Jose what do you have to say
about it Dominic
hi uh thank you so much for taking my
call guys
um so basically uh I'm a bit of uh at
first I call it fires or more so I think
it's more buyer's deal because it's
something that like I can justify but
it's something that I just don't think
is was quite in line with what did you
buy Dominic we can't wait to hear this
this time I think I might be overplaying
it maybe I'm not maybe uh but I bought a
new car oh newer car what did you buy
I bought a 2020 Tesla Model 3. 2020
Tesla Model 3 and what's that set you
back
it sent me back uh like out the door it
was uh 41.3 oh boy you bought everything
and you even are talking like the car
guy out the door he told you I'll get
this for you right now Dominic out the
door 41 000 you're like yes please well
what's your income
no you didn't tell me that I had to
figure it out myself but um I make
uh 115 before taxes oh yeah what's the
payment on this beauty
it is 687 a month oh gosh
okay I gotta get a Pepto-Bismol J
takeover well technically we would tell
people that anything going down in value
like a vehicle you shouldn't do more
than 50 percent have more than 50 of
your annual income tied up in that so
you're under that I think my guess is
just maybe you've never had a car
payment that's this costly and you're
feeling it and I don't like car payments
period but what was your car situation
before you got into this Tesla
so I actually had a paid off car that's
what it is yeah and I and at the time I
was like yes I just want to not have a
car payment I was like 11k I paid it off
in like a couple months because I didn't
have a little cash right on hand but um
basically oh recently in recent times uh
I don't know I just I started thinking
about like oh maybe I would enjoy having
something a bit more luxurious you know
rather than driving something so old and
I convinced myself into doing it I
didn't and I'm like and I did that the
math and I was like yeah I can afford it
and you know I went through with it and
now I'm sitting here and I'm just
looking at that much debt coming from
having zero debt whatsoever is just like
my heart's sank so you called us so why
did you call us Dominic what's the
question in here
um I'm kind of trying to figure I'm kind
of between two decisions so I talked
about it with my fiance
and she is telling me that it's probably
just best to keep the car just pay it
off as quick as possible because I I'm
able to pay off the car uh in less than
30 months if I just make double payments
and I can afford that I encounter that
when I was doing the math and she likes
let's let's throw that out there and she
likes riding in the Tesla come on yeah
no she's like please don't get rid of
the car I love your car all right what's
the second option we got about a minute
we want to help you out what's the
second option
uh section second option is to uh sell
the car privately or trade it in and
then just get a cheaper car what can you
get for it if you sell it
um privately about uh Reserve uh say I
would say like 31. so I'd be losing like
10 grand off of like yeah you know what
yeah it's really there's not a wrong
answer here it's your only debt like I
said you're kind of I I don't want
anybody to have a car note I don't want
them to go into that but you're kind of
under that threshold
um you just hate having the payment and
I don't blame you because you went from
not having any payments to having a
payment and it sucks so for you you know
if your girlfriend is like get out of
the car and you're like get out of the
car then sell it you know take that
stupid tax of ten thousand dollars and
you're just gonna have to bite the
bullet on that and then get into
something in cash or start saving
towards that so you can make it happen
that's what I would do
yikes you know I'm telling you I mean
he's got the money if he wanted to just
write it out and pay it off I I think
I'd get after it I think I'd I'd pay it
off and learn this lesson turn that hate
into a newfound emotion that you can't
even describe to get out of this thing
faster than you could possibly imagine
[Music]
foreign
you are listening to the Ramsay show
where else can you go to just talk about
money can you can't talk to you know you
don't talk to your friends about money
maybe some of y'all aren't even talking
to your spouse about money you need to
start and maybe that conversation can
start here today will help you with
whatever it is that you're dealing with
will help give you advice will help push
you to do the next right step for your
situation but you got to give us a call
the number is triple eight eight two
five five two two five my name is Jade
again this is Ken sitting next to me and
we want to talk about your situation so
we're going to do that we got Eric and
Yuma Arizona I've been to Yuma what's
going on Eric wow oh thanks for taking
my call Kenny Jay you're welcome how can
we help
all right I'm 56 years old I make 90 000
a year I have 130 and a 401k and about 3
000 in an HSA that I only use as a
retirement tool
uh I currently live in a RV that's worth
about 35
000. uh yes it is down by the river
I have a paid for truck
it's worth 32 a boat
at ten thousand and add another SUV at
2500 and an enclosed trailer that I use
for storage I'm to the end of step two
except for about 8 000 on the RV and
knowing that it's just short-term living
until I can get into a house should I go
ahead and just make the minimum payments
on the RV and go ahead and start step
three and three B
you know so that I can move
faster towards a house uh how much is
the Army on Earth
they're already thirty five thousand
okay so it's even
um
my thought the thought that's going
through my head is if you plan on buying
a house you're going to sell the RV
you're not going to keep it so I wanted
to know I'd pay it off yeah yeah
I I listed as debt because you only have
a little bit to go and if you wait
till you're ready to buy a house to pay
it off you will have lost money on it
even more like you'll go to sell it and
it won't be worth
I was wanting to move directly from the
RV into a house so and then just maybe
sell the RV later and whatever I get out
RV I can bump into the uh into the
mortgage how much you have saved up for
the house
I don't have anything that's why I need
to move on to step three and three B I
only have my thousand dollar
okay I misunderstood I thought you said
that you had paid I miss those you have
debt on all those things you listed out
no no he's paid off his boat the issue
okay the Darby is the last step in Step
gotten okay and I only have about 8 000
on it so so if you sold here if you sold
it now would that give you enough money
for a down payment in Yuma Arizona
uh well no he'd still be upside down
depends on how much house I found and
how much I build and that's another
question between the 15 years of income
production left in my life and my
working opportunity so how much house
can I have and how much do I put toward
investing what you need to do here's
what I think that I would do because you
said you you're earning what's your
income 90k did I hear that it's a good
salary I don't see why and who else is
involved in your life are you married do
you have no no divorce so with a 90k
income I don't see why you can't knock
out this AKA 80 I'm sorry 8K on the RV
lickety-split get that out of your life
and then you should have plenty of money
there's no more debt so you should have
plenty of money to quickly save uh what
you want for whether it's a a condo that
you're purchasing a town home I'm not
sure what size home you're looking for
um but now is a good time to kind of
start looking okay what's my life going
to look like you don't want to bite off
more than you can chew
um and really see what that what you you
can afford yeah Eric the reason I would
rather you sell the RV now because that
is depreciating quickly and so I want to
get the most for it and if I sell it now
for 35 two things I get out of that
number one obviously I pay off the eight
grand that I owe on it and now you're
completely debt free and then I've got a
nice chunk of cash that I can begin to
build on if I rent for a year or
whatever or uh you know I get something
smaller because it's just you that's
what I'm thinking Jade I'd rather him
capitalize on getting rid of this this
depreciating asset quickly yeah that's
possible he could do I mean you could
definitely do that I don't know
I'm not mad at that plan
all of these things are going down in
value So based on our math what he's
asking what kind of what kind of house
should he be looking at Jade knowing
that we're already off and running on a
nice down payment if we sell several
things well I'm when I'm thinking about
the RV is I'm thinking about that versus
renting for however much time it's going
to take for him to get the money for the
house I don't know that he needs to rent
well where is he going to go well he
buys a smaller buys a smaller house I
want to figure out what with what you
can do with your 90k you got no debt you
look at your monthly budget your take
home you sell a couple things can you
get up to fifty thousand dollars could
you amass 50 000 pretty quickly I
thought I heard that much money in there
right and I agree I I had thought about
selling my truck and drive just drive
the SUV which was not
they don't need two cars for years to
get right well it's just what was left
from nine meter truck you know and I've
just not got rid of it yet yeah I don't
think you need two vehicles yeah you've
got options it's for you it's all about
how quickly can we get there and I'm
trying to get to home ownership as
quickly as possible so I can pay off the
homeowners can you buy a 250 I don't
know Yuma so I'm going somewhere with
all these Goods can you buy a 250 000
house
in Yuma oh you can buy 250 000 mobile
homes and you know
I would not buy anymore I'm not a mobile
home I'm not buying a mobile home so I
know that I'm not that's just the way
prices are here okay so it's what could
you afford yeah what could you get for
what you're looking for what does it
cost well my thought is it's a small a
three bedroom two bath just a simple
clean house you know that uh in 10 to 12
years I can pay off and put as much
Equity into and if I have to after that
point sell and downside well what does
that cost
two to three hundred thousand dollars
okay so again I'm not the mathematician
in the room but if I sell the RV at 35
and I owe eight all right all right now
I'm walking away with some money there
and then I got a truck and then I got a
boat and I'm going can I get close to 50
000 and you're making 90. how quickly
can you get fifty thousand dollar down
payment that's a really Stellar down
payment that's a 20 on something but
there's something in the 250 range right
am I wrong you're not wrong Ken Coleman
I'm just saying dude and now we get rid
of the RV which is not helping you long
term that's true you can part with the
RV it's just a short it's just a
short-term answer and I
was looking at probably staying in the
RV maybe another year and filing up as
much money and selling the boat I like
kids I like Ken's option because if you
start selling if you sell the truck then
you sell the boat the last thing to go
is the RV and you come up with you know
a little short-term solution until it's
time to get the house that you want I
think that's the way to stack up that
cash as quickly as possible I'm trying
to come up with 23 Grand that's what I
need to come up with because you got the
27 if you sell the RV at 35 and you 08
so now I'm there I need to come up with
23 more 50 000 is pretty darn close to
the kind of down payment we'd want him
to put on it that's right ideally yes
yes that's right and we've got another
rule that we're working with which is
the amount of assets that he has that
are going down in value for his income
yeah we've got a 35 000 deal something
that's worth 25 000 something that's
worth ten thousand dollars in another
vehicle the truck the SUV the boat the
RV is too much
we gotta offload some of it and it's way
better to throw that money into
something that's going up in value as
quickly and as possible as a home actual
freestanding home that's what I'm doing
10 to 15 years left you know I've got to
start putting as much more into my
investments and I think that will be a
home yeah Eric I think this is a good
move I love this plan this fast forwards
everything for you oh by the way yeah
you're debt free except for the home
yeah and now you can pay that off and
you're golden I know that's right the
key here is he can't bite off too much
home like he's really got to keep that
hey I was looking at you to make sure my
numbers were added no I liked it I think
he couldn't find something he said
between two and 300 and he's got the
assets to be able to make a really solid
down payment right now I think that's
good that RV if he you're right that
thing can drop like a rock if he's not
too too careful so really good stuff the
key here is walking those baby steps in
order looking at what you've got around
you looking at what you can sell in his
case he's probably not picking up a
bunch of side hustles but he's got a lot
of stuff laying around that he can sell
to get that money and you should get
that money this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
this is the Ramsay show the only place
where you can go to get real talk the
real deal on your finances on your
mental health questions on your career
questions because we've got Ken Coleman
on the show today and you can give us a
call the number is triple eight eight
two five five two two five the scripture
in the quote of the day is this
I will not cause pain without allowing
something new to be born says the Lord
that's Isaiah 66 9. that's a good one I
will not cause pain without allowing
something new to be born
that's good that's good in retrospect
Drew Barrymore said this life is very
interesting in the end some of your
greatest pains become your greatest
strengths that's a word it's growing
something it's nothing's wasted is what
they're saying yeah nothing is ever
wasted that is so so good all right
let's go to Jonathan or let's go to John
in Atlanta Georgia that's what happens
when I take my glasses off what's going
on John
hey um I I have kind of an interesting
situation
um I'm it and it's more so I'm looking
for career advice sure
um so I uh I I'm in a career where I I
handle marketing
um I make about 120 000 per year
um I have a nice 401K nice benefits
package
um
going back five years ago I went through
kind of the worst nightmare in terms of
of uh direct debt and career choices I
had to sell our house
um we had sixty thousand dollars worth
of debt which may not seem like much but
it was a lot to me at the time and we
use the equity in our house to pay off
that debt ended up moving and just just
a big spiral of uh a nasty situation
um since then I've kind of made it my
mission to get out of debt and and to go
beyond that so I started
um doing side hustles and and uh doing
contract work on the side
um my expertise is in really uh
political and and very nuanced marketing
and Communications and I was able to
build something up uh very successful in
that um and each year it's it's grown
um and I'm I'm trying to figure out when
when I should make the switch to doing
that full-time because it's what started
out as kind of Moonlighting in in
contract work has turned into in reality
me working two full-time jobs how much
how much are you making on the side
Hustle
so uh
every year it's grown uh in 2016 I made
twenty thousand 2018
political it's it's every other year
right uh 2018 I made 50 000 2020 I made
a hundred thousand and last year I made
um and this year is the first year in an
odd year that I actually made made some
income so I made 76 of this year
um so it's it's kind of stacking up
um my my
I I my gut is telling me that it's it's
time to make a switch
um John John my friend uh your gut is is
a crazy in alignment with my gut
um this is a good move for you man
um I assume you've been stacking this
money in the in this separate account or
are you paying yourself some of it
a a little bit of both um we've been
primarily living on
um the the main income for my good I was
hoping you were gonna say that so how
much do you have in the side business
account
uh well I don't keep much in the
business account but um but are you
keeping it where are you keeping it
uh
and I I'm essentially taking it as as
salaries and dividends so you are yeah
but you just told us that you were
paying yourself just a little bit you
were living off your main gig well I I
it's it's
it's coming into my pocket and then I'm
using it for for Investments 401ks I'd
rather not keep it in a bank account
wait wait wait wait here's the problem
with that John
um that money I understand you're paying
yourself and you're doing it the right
way and dividends everything else but I
want that money in that account because
if I'm going to walk away from my
full-time job I gotta have that money in
the account to pay me
yeah and there's ways that you can
invest through your business so you're
not having to pull out all the money
do you see what I'm saying like if you
set up the right type of simple 401K you
could do a contribution through the
business and then you could do a
contribution based on your payroll as
well your personality part of this is
that this has snowballed over the last
five years and like I I'm working two
full-time jobs I haven't really found
the the right way to to handle
you know spooling all that up and and
um so
let's help you with that like you're
thinking too hard yeah all right so
here's what I would do if I were you
um
I would I would not walk so you're in an
off here right now
um I would the 75 you're going to make
this year if it were me I would have put
it all and I would kept I would have
kept it in the bank in the business
account and I want what I tell people is
you can move from your side hustle to
your full to you can move from your
full-time gig to your side hustle when
it is spitting off enough to take care
of your needs what you require in salary
and you've got a minimum of six months
of your salary in the bank that's what
my doesn't mean that I'm right I love
that that's what I would do I would have
six months of my salary so you make 120.
so six months of that so sixty thousand
I'd have in the business account that
would be six months before I stepped
away and resigned and said I'm out okay
that's what I would do and is that on
top of your typical three to six months
uh well almost expensive expenses
well no because it's not it's it's my
point is is that I'm not it's not about
the baby steps on that particular
situation because it's his new salary so
he could still be working his baby steps
but he'd have six months oh you're
saying yes it does not include the
emergency fund this is this is in the
business account this is my salary yes
that I'm walking into so I like that
separate because because I don't want
anybody ever touching their emergency
fund for salary exactly and that's why I
love this Ken okay so I say minimum six
months and if you have the 75 which I
feel like you've been paying yourself
some of that so I would stock it back up
before I left
because I want you to leave
because you've already got a pipeline
and I think you're gonna be fine I think
this is a no-brainer but I wish you had
more money in the side hustle bank
account your business I wish you had
more in there so that when you walk away
you're not thinking about anything but
building that business and I want you to
take better care
um because I might be wrong but what you
said is like hey I'm pulling everything
out of the business I'm taking that as
payroll and I'm turning around taking
that money and investing it I want to be
a little more Savvy on how we're doing
that because I mean you're gonna have to
pay taxes on that you're gonna pay
payroll taxes on both sides as the
employer and as the employee just to
invest it where you could leave some of
that money in the business and have more
tax advantage by investing into your own
solo 401K through the business are you
doing that do you have a sep
or something no I don't and I just
hadn't I I hadn't gotten to that point
yet where it was appropriate I mean last
year I mean you got a lot of money
coming out uh bro I'm gonna tell you
right now when you started making 100
Grand or more it was appropriate you
didn't even paying taxes
yeah okay I just want to be sure okay
you had me over here sweating John okay
no no in fact I overpaid this year
because I'm getting something okay good
good good yes I just want to make sure
you're doing that but um is your wife
working too
no
um part part of this was um our son has
has some medical conditions and so in
order for her to stay home
I I started doing contract work and it
just good okay I think you're ready my
friend but I would prefer that you stack
it up a little bit more and don't pull
the trigger yet you've done it this far
unless let me say this unless you're
fried because you're working two
full-time jobs and I can hear that in
your voice I think you might be on the
verge of frying is that right
well yeah I I would say so well then I
would uh I mean you're ready I think you
could move some money around and and
boost up maybe beyond your emergency
fund some of the stuff you've done I
mean I don't know I I'd be smart with
this but I think it's time it's time for
you to commit and go all in
I love it that's good that's a great
call guys a stud I love that and you had
so many good nuggets that I think so
many people can use in their journey to
transitioning from whatever job it is to
don't take a leap with nothing to LEAP
into it is not glamorous that's a fact
you gotta you gotta create a net
can't just be jumping without a net make
it that only works right with cartoons I
know that's right all right guys that
does it for this hour of the Ramsey show
this last three hours we've enjoyed
hanging out with you and remember when
it comes to your money you can tell me
you won't do it but don't tell me you
can't do it
hey what's up guys it's Jade look if you
like what you heard in this episode and
want to know more about getting started
on the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramsesolutions.com and click the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]